my name's Nicola Revere I'm a kernel
developer at Wolfram research and I work
primarily on various frameworks within
the language primarily date and time
also our quantity framework and also as
part of our client-side management for
entity and the Wolfram knowledge base I
do a lot of audit end projects also but
I primarily focus on those core
frameworks and data structures in the
language today I want to give a overview
of how we think about date and time
within the Wolfram language some of the
new features we've added since version
10 and particularly since version 11 and
the way that we're planning on expanding
and flushing at our date framework in
the future so just a brief overview I
want to go over a sort of a high-level
description of how we work with dates
and times within the language and then
look specifically at data object which
is our canonical representation of dates
within the language and then the
different constituent components that
now make up a date object and why we use
these particular components and why
they're necessary to resolve time and
then at the end I want to talk about
some upcoming features that we're
working on and some other things that
we're kicking around and then get
feedback if anyone has anything that
they think is a priority or an
interesting aspect they'd like to see
explored more in the language so very
basics time is one of the primary
physical quantities associated with the
way we experience the universe its
indefinite period that stretches from
past includes present and future and is
generally used to describe events or the
progress of events throughout our
experience generally when we think about
time we think about it in concrete
aspects of either dates like today's
October 18th 2018 or as durations so a
period of five minutes and when looking
at these it's sometimes nice to look at
the analogy between physical space and
time and the way that those different
constituent components interact so
within physical space we think about the
you know the the analogy of
three-dimensional space and time is not
exact because we're working with a
single dimension that runs from past
future but if we think about a single
instance in visible space we think about
a position within geodesy we think about
a geo position the analogy to that in
time is a date it's a specific period of
time
that's discrete and unique and are
welcome language representation of that
is a date object we have other
representations but they're generally
more limited and describing time when we
think about something in physical space
as a distance the separation between two
discrete objects the analogy and time is
a duration in the Wolfram language would
represent this as a quantity so a
quantity of five seconds or five hours
or five minutes but when we think about
the way those relate to a calendar which
is essentially a projection on a date
it's a framework for us to conceptually
understand the the way that dates are
structured today being October 18 2018
is only meaningful within the framework
of the Gregorian calendar it's what
we're used to thinking about with dates
but because date is an infinite span in
both directions there's no real
beginning of time or end of time we
essentially choose an arbitrary
reference point and then all of our
conceptions within a calendar relate
back to that reference point and another
aspect I want to talk about towards the
end of the talk is time systems which
you can think again comparing to geodesy
and geo positions it's like the datum
it's how we understand that this
specific point was measured so when we
talk about what time is it right now
we're talking about how we understand
what now is in terms of that infinite
span of time how we resolve it down to
both a calendar but also to a specific
moment and that come that becomes
important when we do things like
accounting for leap seconds and
differences between different time
measures
so our primary representation of dates
within the language is date object it is
an expression that acts both as a
constructor and as a container in terms
of being a constructor if we take a data
object it will give you the current
instant in time if you don't specify any
other arguments so if I evaluate data
object it will give me this current
moment Thursday October 18th 2018 at 104
and will include a timezone and other
parameters that are needed to resolve
that date to a specific moment we use
this to generate the specific dates that
we're looking at and we can take any
number of potential arguments so
historically mathematic is supported
strings as representations of time lists
as representations of time and numeric
values as representations of time all
with their own implicit reference
framework and data object-- knows how to
take these and construct a canonicalized
expression for us to use in the language
data objects can also be used to
construct from other data objects so we
can take for example a data object that
represents a specific moment in time and
effectively mod it down to a granular
data object which represents a day
without the the resolution going down to
a specific instant data objects also
represent containers in the language in
that we once we've constructed a deja
data object we use the same expression
to carry that information around but the
container form of data object doesn't
necessarily carry around options it
carries around arguments so a data
object has a date representation a
granularity a reference calendar and a
time zone and from this container there
are any number of properties we can
extract some of them relate to the
string representation of the date some
of them represents like the time zone we
can use that container information to
determine things like is the year that
it's contained in a leap year etc if we
break down a little further the way that
data object is actually structured is
divided into four parts and those
constituent elements are the
date part or the representation we use
to describe the specific moment in time
the granularity which describes the
calendar granularity or calendar step
associated with that date the calendar
type which is important for referencing
both the date part and the granularity
in the time zone and all four of those
are necessary to describe a unique
moment in time and one of the quirks of
having data object be both a constructor
and container is that the head itself
may represent a valid data object or it
may represent something that happens to
have date objects so we include this
predicate of data object q that looks at
any given expression lets you know if it
actually is a data object so for example
something that could be interpreted as a
data object but hasn't been yet is not
data object q so when we look at the
representation of a date within data
object what we're looking at is the way
that the specific calendar we're using
chooses to categorize time so if we look
at the first argument of a canonically
generated data object it is essentially
the same thing as a date list we
separate the field data into year month
day hour minute and second and those
values can those values correspond to
important elements associated with a
calendar but we don't necessarily always
need to use a list to describe these so
for example we have a calendar that
we're introducing which uses a strictly
numeric value to represent time because
we're referencing an absolute time
calendar which has its own implicit
rules and doesn't need a list
representation it's defined
fundamentally in the number of seconds
that have elapsed since January 1st 1900
we have a number of different
representations of dates within the
Wolfram language any of these
potentially could be used as a first
argument for data object provided the
calendar understands them we generally
use date lists as our historical
reference point where we break things
into six elements but there are many
calendars that wouldn't necessarily use
six elements or may not want to use a
list at all so absolute time is a
numeric value so is Julian date and unix
time and they all implicitly refer
two different two different unit steps
from in a time epoch but with date
object we can actually carry that
information around we don't need to know
that this number was a unix time that
was generated by this unix function i
need to assume that it's based on this
value we could actually carry that along
with the data object and we don't
necessarily need to pull everything back
to being in its list for sidereal time
I've included on here is not exactly the
same sort of representation of a date
because sidereal time is on essentially
a 24-hour clock but it's an another
representation that uses quantities in
this in this form to represent the
progression of time throughout the day
by looking at the the night ephemeris
time but essentially looking at the your
position on the globe in the way that
the the right Ascension and declination
combined to give you a parent time
associated with the rotation of the
earth so the big thing that we've added
since version 10 and early on in version
11 is granularity the way that we
describe granularity is that it
represents a calendar object associated
with a given calendar so a granular you
know for example we have two different
convenience constructs of now and today
they represent objects within a given
period of time but they have a different
resolution or different granularity and
in many ways this granularity determines
the way that we think about the date
object and the way that we handle
algebra associated with a data object
you know if someone asks you what your
birthday is you generally don't give
them the absolute instant that you were
born there's a certain resolution
associated with that factoids and
granularity gives us a way to represent
any number of possible calendar steps
all within a unified framework we could
potentially have a year object that
exists and has its own properties or a
month object but within a granular
framework we can both take explicit
parameters within the date list since
our Gregorian dates tend to have year
month day hour
second we can represent all of those but
we can also extend those granularities
to cover extended periods so for example
with Gregorian calendars as a reference
we have 16 different possible
granularities some of them cover the
same period of time so we have two
versions of millennium one of them
beginning on a Year Zero increment and
one beginning on gear one depending on
what your reference model is we could
generalize this to include decade or any
number of things but it allows us to
take the information that's part of the
calendar itself and affect the way that
we handle granularity and arithmetic
associated with those data objects
because one of the characteristics of
working with data objects is that they
use relative calculations in terms of
time if I say what is the date a year
from now you probably aren't looking at
a specific number of ticks on a cesium
atomic clock difference between now and
then you mean October 18th 2019 and that
arithmetic is fundamentally determined
by the calendar you're associated with
and having these granular steps be
essentially in lock with that notion
gives us a lot of flexibility in the
language so that we can describe things
like a year a month with a implicit
region associated with them we know when
this year starts and when this year ends
but we don't need to do all of our
arithmetic PIN to the specific endpoints
we can look at it associated strictly
with that calendar step and implicitly
determine how we need to handle those
endpoints later on any calculations we
also introduced a number of convenience
structures they're convenient
constructors associated with granularity
so we have current next and previous
dates which take a granularity and
optionally a reference date so if I want
to know what month it is I can evaluate
current date of month or what year it is
current date of year and it will give me
the granular step associated with the
current timestamp so if I want next year
I can say next date of year or I can
give a reference date for previous date
and say I want to know what week was
before Wednesday April 3rd of 2013 and
it will give me a granular object that
is a week beginning on Monday as our as
our week granularities canonically do
and it will take it in reference to that
original input date this is generalized
in terms of handling granularity and we
also allow day types so for version 12
we're introducing support for day types
where weekend day reference is a day
granular object but it has criteria
associated with it so I want the next
day that falls on a weekend or I wanted
the previous Wednesday or I want the
next Saturday I can generate the same
value but Sunday I can generate a
granular object with reference to the
specific criteria that's implied by that
day type you can also do convenient
calculations like if I want to know what
the weekday immediately preceding
Thanksgiving is I can provide a
reference date and then say the criteria
is I want what it to be a weekday we
also support comparisons between
granular data objects so for example I
can test either through sorting or
strictly by comparison that today
precedes tomorrow or I can ask is today
the same thing as now and equal
understands that the granularity step
means that now falls within the period
of today so there's not really an
equivalence test that we could give a
true or false to so in this case we give
a warning message and we return on
evaluated one of the ways we can handle
that is that we include containment
functions which give us a way of
breaking down the relationship between
different data objects so that same
evaluation before I can look at does now
fall within today and it does I can also
look at tests to see whether the
following Sunday is within this week is
the following Monday within this week no
it's not and for so David Thank You Tex
test for total containment and we also
have date overlaps q which tests for
partial containment so does the last
week of October fall within October it
does not
fully contained because part of it spans
over to November so date overlaps cue
will return true of a date with NQ or
turn false for calendar types we support
a number of different calendar types
within the language and they all have
different canonical representations for
since version 11 we've supported six
primary calendars Gregorian which is
generally what is implied if you don't
otherwise specify a calendar type we
also support the Hebrew calendar which
is known as the Jewish calendar the
ummah kora
islamic calendar and - iso calendars for
iso weekdays and iso day years so the
iso ordinal calendar for example
provides the year you're in and the day
within the year but there's no notion of
a month and similarly is a week calendar
provides the year the week within the
year and the day within the week so they
have different implied granularities
associated with the different arguments
we're also working on extending the
framework to support additional
representations that can either use
numeric values so a date object with a
Julian date in it or a date object with
a unix time in it or in the future split
of split calendars which for in this
example for absolute time has the number
of seconds since 1900 and then partial
seconds separate which can become
important in the future for things like
date array where we may want to be able
to pack the specific arguments
associated with it their additional
calendars that may be useful that we're
looking at adding in the future the
japanese Gengo calendar for example is
based on the Gregorian calendar but
instead of referring to the year 2018
you referred to the current year would
be hey say 30 so the thirtieth year of
the current imperial dynasty within
japan is the Mesoamerican count calendar
which uses the CG mole steps of units
except for one specific unit which is in
steps of 18 but we basically have seven
days and then sixteen steps of eighteen
days and then five steps of twenty of
those steps and each thing moving up an
additional base of 20 they're also
lunisolar calendars that
look at either tropical or Siberia years
and the moon phase together which is
something that becomes important when
we're looking at astronomical
calculations in the future being able to
model planetary bodies moving throughout
the universe and around the around the
globe for time zones we have four
primary representations of time zones in
the Wolfram language we use numeric
offsets from GMT it's easy to think that
time zones are broken down into 24
different hour periods within on the
across the globe right now there are
actually 38 different time zones because
not everything is broken down by an hour
we support any numeric representation of
a time zone it doesn't necessarily need
to correspond to one of those known GMT
offsets so I can say I want a data
object that it's a time zone of six
point seven hours ahead of GMT we
generally look back to your dollar sign
time zone to initialize what that
default numeric offset is we also
support since version 10 time zone IDs
they're also sometimes referred to as
internet time zones and the way that we
handle these is by looking up a
reference point to a geographic region
that defines how we transition both
between daylight savings and non
daylight saving time if it's observed
but also historically how time is moved
so for example there is no central time
zone in a time zone ID we reference
America Chicago if you want to look at
sort of the messy history of time zones
there at the United States you can see
that Indiana has had a particular
particularly fractious relationship with
time zones Evansville has been in
central time since the time zone was
incepted but knox county has moved time
zones they've changed offsets regularly
the same thing has happened throughout
part of North Dakota and part of
Wisconsin in these times our IDs take
into account the fact that if I move 60
years back in the past I may have a
different offset than I do
right now we also for convenience allow
low K ssin and it is to be specified for
time zones and will effectively look up
what that times at the time zone
associated with that location is so I
can say my time zone is Bismarck and it
will look up and know okay
Bismarck is in Central time we also
added support for time zone none
recently which allows you to generate a
data object with no explicit time zone
so for example if I have if I generate a
time zone and send it to someone at a
different time zone it will still
represent the same reference point for
them a time zone of none will
effectively delay the use of
instantiation for that time we still
have a reference time that's generated
for the representation but we don't have
an interpretation associated with when
that falls on a GMT offset unless I need
to do something like date list or date
string at which point it will know what
time zone it should use there one notion
that I wanted to mention briefly that
we're working on that isn't immediately
available is time zone notation that
includes a time zone ID and an offset
this is particularly important because
neither of those is completely
sufficient to fully resolve all moments
in time in a couple of weeks we're gonna
transition off of daylight saving time
here and we're gonna have two different
two a.m. so 2 a.m. to 3 a.m. and then we
will reset fallback in our new 2 a.m. to
3 a.m. again if you strictly use a time
zone ID only we don't know which of
those two to a.m. you're talking about
and again in spring when we jump forward
an hour there's an hour that doesn't
exist if we use just the ID or just the
offset we can't fully resolve down that
one period of ambiguity around daylight
savings time and so in the future we
want to have time zones be able to
support both of those specifications so
for that period I could
concretely nail down what 2 a.m. i'm
talking about or if i'm working with
something like a time object that
doesn't have a reference date i'll be
able to say okay this was 6:00 p.m.
central time but it was back
January so it had a different offset
than I have right now so we can see in
these tables that the difference between
the gmt offset and the chicago times
start to diverge after a two hour
difference from the onset or offset of
GMT so the last feature I want to talk
about is one that is not currently in
the Wolfram language but it's something
we're looking at extending which is the
notion of time systems I mentioned at
the beginning that a time system is
somewhat analogous to a datum within a
Geo position it basically tells you how
you measured what time it currently is
if someone asks you what time it is and
you look at your watch you're generally
looking at a watch that's been
synchronized with some other source
typically it's based off of coordinated
Universal Time or UTC which is a
approximation of UT of universal time
standard one and the the complication
here is that throughout history we
basically would look up at the Sun and
use that as our apparent solar time as
our reference point for what time
something was the closer we were at at
noon the higher the Sun was and we had a
good reference point but early on in the
20th century we realized oh the Earth's
orbit isn't perfectly elliptical so
there are different periods where we
have a different offset and you know for
example this graphic at the top shows
that a full rotation of the earth when
we're looking at the Sun we've actually
over corrected for our apparent location
relative to the Sun and if we were to
look at a distant point in space or use
something like a femoris time we would
have a different point on the clock and
the difference of a few microseconds is
not major for many date calculations but
once we start talking about bodies
moving through space the DIF being off
by a second or off by a few milliseconds
can represent a very large change in
distance so we want to be able to
support things like International atomic
time or coordinated Universal Time or
geocentric coordinate time the
coordinate time that's used by GPS
systems which do not account for leap
seconds they don't care about the
rotation of the earth they were
synchronized with Ti a back in the 1960s
and since then don't need to do any
correction because they're not concerned
with exactly how
the earth is rotating and because the
earth is slowly slowing down it means
that we have to keep adding leap seconds
in and there are different ways we
accommodate that because even though
we've redefined the fundamental
definition of what a second is in terms
of cycles of a cesium clock it turns out
that if you put atomic clocks on
different parts of the earth they run at
slightly different speeds because the
geomagnetic forces and the gravity well
of you know of the planet Earth is not
uniform so the other systems like GPS t
simulates an atomic clock that follows
the rotation of the earth but exists
somewhere out in the vacuum of space and
isn't affected by the Earth's
geomagnetic field it's something that
we're looking at implementing in the
Wolfram language and we hope to be able
to do things like map between these
different coordinate systems of time so
that we can handle astronomical
calculations and things in the future
additional features we're looking at our
conclusion of things like temporal logic
which is a modal logic operator related
to time being able to say things like I
am hungry and I will be hungry until I
eat so eventually I will not be hungry
anymore date intervals are a concept of
relating extended periods of time but
still representing discrete moments so I
can represent the time between now and
two weeks from now
recurring dates are useful in scheduling
notation and give us a way of
representing things like recurring
holidays and date arrays are something
that we're also pretty excited about
being able to efficiently represent a
large collection of dates and ideally be
able to pack them as well so if I have
three million time stamps and I want to
combine them down into a single object
that can carry them around it'd give us
the ability to manipulate and keep that
relatively small but also be able to
perform arithmetic on it without having
to unpack everything and shift things
around so it looks like I'm running out
of time here but if anyone has any
questions